these black garments represent
a typical feature of an undeveloped
and inner animal figure that would mean
that his whole
capacity of love is mostly autoerotic
when a man has not developed his animal
his feminine side is very nice generally
very narcissistic
that's what women painfully feel that
when a
man in love is meowing under her window
like a
tomcat in love he really loves his own
fantasy
he loves his own being in love but
there's a long way for him to learn to
love her
and not enjoying his own being
in love and if you read
in literature a young man when he
generally discovers the experience of
love
it's mostly a completely autoerotic
fantasy out of which he has
through a painful development
learned to love the woman not as the
object of his romantic fantasies but as
a human
human partner
what does this inner transformation mean
in terms of the man's relationship to an
actual woman in outer life
the peeling of the black anima and their
transformation in a white golden animal
is the transformation of the loving
capacities
of a man of a transformation of his eras
from a primitive autoerotic fantasy
into a true human capacity for love
as soon as this transformation takes
place he then is attacked
by primitives who want to keep the the
woman that she should remain
black and stay with the blacks in a
black village so there is
a strong primitive tendency to relapse
again
into the old attitude but the dreamer
can't successfully fight it off